et pour mieux comprendre les
conséquences de ce virage à gauche de la
grèce reçoit maintenant frédéric mérand
il est directeur du cérium le centre
d'études de recherches internationales
de montréal
non monsieur mélenchon alors on
l'entendait un reportage de sylvain des
grecs réagir ça suscite évidemment de
l'espoir l'arrivée de syriza au pouvoir
c'est tout un changement quand même pour
la grèce oui le problème c'est que si
près ça fait deux promesses qui sont
possiblement contradictoires d'une part
il a promis d éliminer ou en train de
diminuer la dette que les grecs on
entretienne à l'endroit des autres pays
européens
et d'autre part il veut mettre un terme
toutes les réformes
certaines très durs qui ont été mises en
oeuvre depuis quatre ans le problème
c'est que pour obtenir un
rééchelonnement de la dette ou une
diminution de la dette
il va devoir faire davantage de réformes
pour plaire à bruxelles pour préparer à
berlin aussi et donc c'est un peu la
quadrature du cercle
ouais parce qu'en face ils ont promis
beaucoup de choses là d'électricité
gratuite pour trois cent mille familles
soins de santé gratuits pour tous
rétablissements du salaire minimum donc
une hausse très forte du salaire minimum
réouverture du télédiffuseur public
est ce qu'il va être en mesure de livrer
s'il doit en même temps renégocier la
dette à court terme il va certainement
mettre en oeuvre plusieurs de ces
réformes qui visent finalement à faire
porter le coup de l'austérité
- sur les peaux et moins sur la classe
moyenne et davantage par exemple chez
les riches et les armateurs le clergé
aussi qu'ils avaient été moins touché
par l'austérité telle qu'appliquée par
la droite d'un pôle ans exactement
donc ça va être sa promesse le problème
c'était les lendemains risquent de
déchanter puisque pour l'instant la
grèce n'a absolument pas d'argent pour
augmenter les dépenses publiques pour
recruter 300 mille fonctionnaires par
exemple met donc pas beaucoup de marge
de manoeuvre
mais est-ce que ça annonce pas des
négociations très difficiles justement
avec l'europe extrêmement difficile
c'est sûr que les européens ont mis un
peu d'eau dans leur vin maintenant exact
cept de par la syriza ce qui n'était pas
nécessairement le cas il ya un ou deux
mois quand merkel
si les grecs votent pour ces visas ça
pourrait signifier la sortie de la grèce
de l'union européenne aujourd'hui on
doit respecter la démocratie quand
exactement
exactement là les conditions qui sont
posées c'est que si la grèce acceptent
de mettre en oeuvre des raisons de
continuer les réformes peut-être des
réformes légèrement différente de celle
qu'ils étaient des mises en oeuvre
depuis quelques années à ce moment là on
pourrait peut-être envisager un
rééchelonnement de la dette c'est-à-dire
de payer sur une plus longue période
avec des taux d'intérêt plus faibles
mais il s'agit pas certainement bernet
mais pas non plus à linky pas non plus à
la il s'agit pas d'éliminer ou de
diminuer considérablement la dette
grecque
bon évidemment c'est le premier parti
anti austérité à prendre le pouvoir en
europe quand même on en a quand même
beaucoup parlé de l'austérité de ce que
ça pouvait faire à une population comme
la grèce est ce que ça pourrait avoir un
effet domino je pense par exemple à
l'espagne qui vit aussi une situation
économique très difficile
c'est sûr que beaucoup de partis
d'extrême gauche mais aussi d'extrême
droite comme le front national en france
vont s'inspirer de l'expérience syriza
pour dire on peut monter un programme
anti austérité et faire tomber les
partis traditionnels sur un programme
essentiellement anti union européenne
aussi pas seulement anti austérité
ça va être beaucoup plus difficile
ailleurs parce que les temps même si la
situation est grave en espagne en italie
- en france il rien de comparable avec
la grèce qui est un pays qui est en
faillite totale depuis plusieurs
décennies où la corruption est largement
répandue le système judiciaire ne
fonctionne pas et l'élite politique
comme on l'a vu avec les résultats de
l'élection et complètement déconsidéré
mais c'est pas seulement donc les
politiques d'austérité qui ont nui à
l'adresse je dirais lavelli politique
avant le problème est largement endogène
propre à la grèce
peut-être que les mesures d'austérité
demandées par bruxelles pour sauver la
grèce ont empiré les choses on peut
avoir un débat là-dessus mais à
l'origine le problème c'est un problème
grec
le problème grec un peu d'espoir quand
même pour la population avec cette
élection
merci beaucoup merci